as the sun rose over the amazon so did
we to see for ourselves what's at stake
in this battle to save the most
biodiverse sanctuary on the planet
a battle witnessed every day by police
pilot rafael montenegro elaine griffey
said
we must fight for this
it's our land
i say sanctuary that's what it was until
a few decades ago now dotted everywhere
like blemishes on nature's masterpiece
the work of reckless farmers and illegal
loggers bent on exploiting this wet and
wondrous place
if you go deeper and deeper and deeper
you see a lot of bigger bigger bigger
areas like that
to combat these we need a
political government to
to engage of the better conditions to
work
it's environmental vandalism where the
vandals have the blessing of bolsonaro
a president who cares little for the
planet a custodian without a conscience
so worried of scientists about what is
happening down here below us that they
fear that if it continues in the way it
is that within a few generations the
amazon rainforest could disappear
to be replaced by some vast dry savanna
land
as more trees are failed and tens of
billions already have been it means less
rainfall higher temperatures more
drought and then consider this stunning
fact the rainforest below us is one
enormous carbon store holding the
equivalent of almost 12 years of global
emissions at current rates
so much of it is criminal yeah i mean
it's criminals down doing a lot of this
stuff
the most part of the floor the forest
here it's a criminal it's illegal
it's not legal so
but we can't give up
we might fight every day
and as we headed back another reason why
this is pollution this is pollution this
is one last grim snapshot of what man is
doing to one of the most beautiful and
important places on earth
mark austin sky news over the amazon